previously on pubes and friends oh hi
and now the season finale of pubes and
frou-frou what is on tap honestly I
didn't ever wearing stage yeah we look
all this [ __ ] good hell I can look at
those women didn't wear a dress wait
wait I need that car come out see you
later
watch it
welcome welcome where is she I need to
go over there
yes good job' I'm wanting one job yeah
let the front man handle this all right
Ronny what's ready well it hasn't taken
for any [ __ ] meds all right Jesus
okay okay yes you seen oil that's more
like it
guys it was a serious crow thing good
thing that was your car look like this
huh look at that is that my car she has
a great haircut she doesn't look like a
12 year old girl she's in the very
convincing so I can get pretty guys like
me scream again look at me get hilarious
I don't like when people make it you're
making Dale missing this hilarious this
thing I'm doing everything it's a funny
look at this [ __ ] she wears beige just
to hide that she sounds well I know her
yeah I know her deal
all right guys be careful I don't want
anyone to die now there's a lot of gassy
who died Hey I don't know how though I
got like [ __ ] head shot 360 [ __ ]
noscope by a fib agent that's it
we're down to the ones that are behind
you get more goes goes got it
granny's gonna get the briefcase granny
got the beef paper I'm gonna jump out
this letter for no reason holy [ __ ] I've
got the briefcase I'm out here I'm
getting in this car can good a black
kept coming getting my cast your steer
stripping
screaming simmer
and no [ __ ] leave me I'm gonna [ __ ]
sasuke-kun this last one yes suck it
suck it sassy [ __ ] all right they're
gone get the briefcase and get the [ __ ]
out no no no we have to wait for the
side get the briefcase I'm going I got
it I got the briefcase all right good
get up doors feschi can get in the
casket can you got a [ __ ] Volvo out
of all the [ __ ] cars walk in oh my
god where the [ __ ] are you God [ __ ]
grandma you should not pick the [ __ ]
moment I shouldn't yet did it good or
this time guys now let's just not run
out and get the briefcase first thing
this time let's kill the agents more and
then it's clear go
stop jumping off and kill yourself can't
tell me what to do [ __ ] I love me some
sass get PES get [ __ ] up I keep
spinning out yeah put a bush here forget
it can't good run Jenkin can't get ready
get ready get ready
we can't any move no we can't animove
unacceptable oh we can think those sense
don't worry I'll draw their fire oh I'm
gonna die I'm gonna die I'm gonna die
what happened Don what happened sounds
good girl I tried to resend Gindin I'm
good no why are you doing what happened
[ __ ] vicious how could I get [ __ ]
flipped out of a god Sam dad did we bury
Sam died I got shot by the enemy in the
wheel ha ha ha ha ha locate again meet
up here I didn't need a baby
Oh face it it was just there someone
just [ __ ] left it in this [ __ ]
wheel I was so [ __ ] hungry yes yes
you're right passage so Ken infuse you
have to do a Titanic at the front of the
boat got to get on the front of the bow
in Titanic this ship they jump in the
water it's too dark I can't it's
beautiful
I literally have wait I'm not in the
world I'm not a baby
[ __ ] hell are we [ __ ] going in
this hangar ba-ba-ba-ba but yeah it goes
just the back this is the terrible
[ __ ] idea mates I'm getting the
aircraft we all have to get one god I
want that [ __ ] this we know the [ __ ]
is this flame to and I can't control
this then [ __ ] you this [ __ ] it isn't
even [ __ ] flying [ __ ] go barrel
sparks you're this perfect [ __ ]
landing shut the [ __ ] up you land I'm
watching him land right now it looks
pretty sweet
Oh God something exploded I think I'm
fine actually I'm actually fine it's
ready you [ __ ] [ __ ] you're a [ __ ]
[ __ ] hey now it's in a desert well by
the power of that grass Oh God dodged
her god I'm getting shot at and multiple
directions
take him down you guys don't know where
I am shut up if we can have no idea how
[ __ ] James Bond granny's right now
I'm almost at Granny's parish you in
forget barrister Brook man just
parachute up the rivers like a three
foot jump but she found oh god oh god oh
god I'll gag off the friggin wall Jesus
sniffing be careful Oh Pierce is going
in Kevin is be careful why's Jeremy
gasps I'm going in I'm going in half it
didn't work guys no this is nice no I'm
putting my Oh get in I'm [ __ ] try
homie then well fine then just get in
excuse me sad oh right I call it
I believe I call Shotgun [ __ ] games I
can't I can't handle it just forget for
over no all right now just go back up
now please we need it yeah we do we know
you do you really do need me I promise
you you're not older
what the [ __ ] is grinding doing up there
granny you crazy-ass [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
already know all right I can see the
helicopter again yeah I can just not die
um I've got it done the water ring
diamond okay cool you know what I
thought did someone just hang up
I think his Internet's going down